يبدو ان الكاتبه الامريكيه كوريرتشنز لم
تتمكن من اخفاء اثار جريمتها على الرغم من
تاليفها كتابا كاملا ينطلق من تجربتها
الشخصيه في فقدان زوجها ويصف حاله الحزن
والحداد بعد وفاته فهي تواجه الان تومه
قتل زوجها
الذي عثر عليه بيتا في غرفتهما في ولايه
يوتا في شهر مارس الماضي قالت الزوجه
حينها انها كانت تعد شرابا لزوجها ووجدته
ميتا في غرفتهما اظهرا تشريح الجثه ان
الرجل مات بسبب جرعه زائده في الفينتانيل
وهي ماده افيونيه صناعيه قويه كان الرجل
قد ابتلع منها خمسه اضعاف الجرعه القاتله
التي اودت بحياته تم القبض على الزوجه من
قبل شرطه ولايه تويوتا بتهمه القتل العمد
وحيازه عقار ممنوع في منزلها بعد تشريح
جثه زوجها خامس المحققون الى ان زوجته
طلبت من احد معارفها تزويدها
بمسكنات قويه للالم وحصلت منه على 30 حبه
من عقار الذي تونه بعد ان صممت زوجها قامت
بتاليف كتاب للاطفال بعنوان هل انت معي
يتكلم عن قصه الطفل فقد والده لكن يتم
تذكيره لانه لا يزال موجودا في كل مكان
حوله قالت انها استلهمت فكره الكتاب من
تجربتها مع اطفالها الثلاثه والذين فقدوا
والدهم